bayonetta fans rejoice the third
installment of the franchise is coming
very very soon plus a bunch of new games
are coming to playstation plus
all this and more on today's game spot
news
bayonetta 3 is releasing this year on
october 28th this upcoming december
would mark the fifth anniversary of its
reveal at the 2017 game awards that
initial announcement happening nearly
four years after the release of
bayonetta 2. so fans have been
desperately awaiting this release in
this third installment bayonetta will be
teaming up with her fellow umbra witches
to face a new threat the homunculi the
game will allow players to also take
control of a new character viola as well
as giving bayonetta new abilities such
as demon masquerade where the titular
character powers up by fusing with an
infernal demon but that's not all a
collector's edition of the game known as
the trinity masquerade edition will be
available for die hard fans this
includes an art book and swappable game
case sleeves that when put together form
a triptych image and what might be the
most amusing news to come out of this
announcement is the game's naive angel
mode bayonetta is well known outside of
the game's player base to the wider
community thanks majorly in part to its
risque nature but fret not all you prude
gamers out there naive angel mode aka
the horny police is here to help with
naive angel mode turned on many of the
game's scantily clad characters
including bayonetta herself will be
provided a few more scraps of cloth to
cover up their most sensitive areas
developer platinumgames notes that this
will hopefully make it easier playing
the game in the living room quote
without creating an awkward atmosphere
if only we had naive angel mode for all
the sex scenes and movies we watched
with our parents
think of all the internal trauma that
could have been avoided
if you're an extra or premium subscriber
to playstation plus the middle and top
tiers of the service a bevy of new games
will become available to you next week
headlining them is the puzzle platformer
cat game set in a cyberpunk world stray
which is launching day and date on
playstation plus also included are final
fantasy 7 remake integrate marvel's
avengers and a ton of assassin's creed
games from the ezio trilogy to unity and
everything in between those games also
get added to the catalog on the same day
astray full details of the lineup add a
link in the description below of course
some of the biggest absences of
playstation plus are the metal gear
solid games a series that helped define
multiple generations of playstation
since last fall metal gear solid 2 and 3
were removed from every digital
storefront thanks to the licenses on
archival footage within them expiring
today on the franchise's 35th
anniversary the official metal gear
twitter account thanked fans of the
franchise and remarked that quote
preparations are underway to make the
temporarily removed titles available
again when those games are made
available again will they come to
playstation plus
only time will tell but it's hard to
imagine a less definitively iconic
pairing of games for playstation than
sons of liberty and snake eater and that
is it for today's gamespot news thanks
for hanging out for more info on
bayonetta 3 as well as that full lineup
of playstation plus games happening next
week head to gamespot.com
[Music]
you